everyone sees what you appear to be
few experience what you really are
it is better to act and repent
than not to act and regret
since love and fear can hardly exist
together
if we must choose between them
it is far safer to be feared than loved
men should be either treated generously
or destroyed
because they take revenge for slight
injuries
for heavy ones they cannot
if an injury has to be done to a man it
should be so severe
that his Vengeance need not be feared
men in general judge Moore from
appearances than from reality
all men have eyes
but few have the gift of penetration
the lion cannot protect himself from
traps
and the fox cannot defend himself from
wolves
one must therefore be a fox to recognize
traps and a lion to frighten wolves
wisdom consists of knowing how to
distinguish the nature of trouble
and in choosing the Lesser evil
make no small plans for they have no
power to stir the soul
where the willingness is great
the difficulties cannot be great
it is a common fault of men not to
reckon on Storms and fair weather
never was anything great achieved
without Danger
a prudent man should always follow in
the path trodden by great men and
imitate those who are most excellent
so that if he does not attain to their
greatness
at any rate he will get some tinge of it
the first method for estimating the
intelligence of a ruler is to look at
the men he has around him
one should never fall in the belief that
you can find someone to pick you up
a battle that you win cancels any other
bad action of yours in the same way by
losing one all the good things worked by
you before become vain
men intrinsically do not trust new
things that they have not experienced
themselves
make mistakes of ambition and not
mistakes of sloth
develop the strength to do bold things
not the strength to suffer
the more sand has escaped from The
Hourglass of our life
the clearer we should see through it
men shrink less from offending one who
inspires love than one who inspires fear
whosoever desires constant success must
change his conduct with the times
men are driven by two principal impulses
either by love or by fear
there is no other way to guard yourself
against flattery
then by making men understand that
telling you the truth will not offend
you
itcher creates few men Brave Industry
and Training makes many
he who is highly esteemed is not easily
conspired against
men sooner forget the death of their
father than the loss of their patrimony
the best Fortress which a prince can
possess is the affection of his people
he who shuns women passes up the trouble
but also the benefits
he who puts up with them gains the
benefits but also the trouble
as the saying goes
there's no honey without bees
everyone who wants to know what will
happen
ought to examine what has happened
everything in this world in any Epoch as
their replicas in antiquity
necessity is what impels men to take
action
and once necessity is gone
only rot and Decay are left
a sign of intelligence is an awareness
of One's Own ignorance
of mankind we may say in general they
are fickle
hypocritical
and greedy for gain
there is nothing as likely to succeed as
what the enemy believes you cannot
attempt
it is not titles that honor men but men
that honor titles
there is no avoiding War it can only be
postponed to the advantage of your enemy
in conclusion the arms of others either
fall from your back or they weigh you
down or they bind you fast
he who builds on the people
Builds on the mud
men will always deceive you unless they
are kept Honest by constraint
everyone around will Envy you if you
tell the truth
the truth
which is profitable
never let others interrupt you because
you will lose respect beware of a man
who interrupts you because he is trying
to show you strength
the vulgar crowd always is taken by
appearances
and the world consists chiefly of the
vulgar
it's far better to earn the confidence
of the people
than to rely on fortresses
he who wishes to be obeyed must know how
to command
men will not look at things as they
really are but as they wish them to be
and are ruined
it is much safer to be feared than loved
because
love is perceived by the link of
obligation which
owing to the baseness of men
is broken at every opportunity for their
advantage
but fear preserves You by a dread of
punishment
which never fails